hello ladies and gentlemen Ryan right in
that house and I'm Jerry in the back
house bathroom we're gonna check out the
official trailer number one for the man
who is actually an aunt or the aunt who
is actually a man both of those original
working titles yes first trailer didn't
really impress me that much to impress
either of us that much but just look
like every it looked like the Marvel
movie the warbles you could just call
that Marvel movie that's the challenge
now yeah it's like they have a really
successful formula and now they have to
start tweaking it to keep it fresh but
then again I remember when I saw the
trailer for Thor I wasn't a big fan but
out of phase one that is one of my
favorites it goes Iron Man I have to
work neighbors still playing music threw
up on their cards where I'm not telling
to shut up you got to make that into a
t-shirt
what's wrong do is just make a bunch of
t-shirts and like obscure rejects
references imagine a soldier the size of
an insect
the ultimate secret weapon you did not
like powers everyone it's gonna be chaos
so how do we stopped him by
nice cool Scott
I've been watching you for a while
you're different and I believe everyone
deserves a shot at redemption do you
absolutely my days are breaking into
places and stealing stuff are over what
do you want me to do I want you to break
into a place and steal some stuff make
sense huh are you ready to become the
hero now the suit has power
you have to learn how to control it
and these are your greatest allies
you're kinda cute when you're small you
have superhuman strength
like a bullet
show me on the bunch show me how to
party
that's how you punch you tried to hide
your suit from me now
it's gonna blow up in your face and
destroy everyone you care about
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] it out here
do you think it would stop the future
you're just a thief
oh man man I know wasn't my idea
hahaha oh yeah that really like really
won me over right that won me over a lot
I'm a square with everybody right now I
forgive me for being a dick and this
isn't a dick thing but I would never not
be sad that egg arrives I'm doing this
movie however I was pretty cool that was
a cool trailer they did make ant-man
look [ __ ] awesome when he was an ant
the way the effects are done his powers
his abilities like it's cool that when
he's small he has superpowers so he's
able to do this super strange [ __ ] it's
a little Greek little insect well that's
the stuff that looked the most cool and
interesting to me is like the whole
thing where he's going through the
tunnels with the ants and stuff like
that and just like shrink him down and
going really tight in on objects and
stuff like that looks really cool and
then the DEET like the details of every
single shot like it looks like they're
really take advantage of his actual
powers I think of like The Incredibles
in The Incredibles what I loved about it
was that it's an animated film so they
knew how to take advantage of the
Fatheads animation this I feel like they
really know what they're like when he's
running up the gun and stuff like that
was so [ __ ] neat to me yeah this looks
awesome the plot looks better cuz we
actually have sort of a plot yeah at
least a little bit yeah I mean there's
gonna be something Isis gets a suit and
it's still pretty vague it's like you
ex-criminal and trusted with superpowers
and this dude's really bad I'm getting a
better sense for what this is the only
question I have still is what exactly
the tones gonna be because I know
they're gonna mix you know cool Morrible
action with humor I'm just wondering to
what degree they're gonna I was
wondering that too because the humor in
it looks like okay that's good humor for
a trailer yeah but what if this is like
such a serious movie and it looks than
the humor feels forced yeah exactly
what's the blend is what I want to know
and what I'm curious to see granted you
want your trailer to communicate exactly
what your movie would feel like
theoretically but this is enough to make
me want to go I want to see how this
plays out on the big screen and what
they finally settled upon cuz that's the
other thing too is now I'm curious
because you know Edgar Wright is so
established that he knows how to make
something that's both humorous but also
heavy if it
needs to be action-packed it means to be
and I'm curious as to what kind of
approach to that this directors going to
bring but then again going back to Thor
felt similar about that trailer too and
exactly what we're talking about I felt
the exact same way when all Marvel
movies have humor and the producers of
Marvel are cool because they get really
involved and I'm sure they'll know how
to capture that it's interesting to me
to be like it's normally we put all our
faith on the creators like the director
and writer but this time I'm like I have
faith in the producers that they know
what they're doing
well then because Marvel is I don't know
obviously but Marvel does seem like as
far as movie studios go it's very
concerned in the quality of their
product more than just making money
usually there's a bad connotation with
like all the producers are really
involved but I think like there's a
reason why because Marvel has a history
it has a legacy it has all these
different stories and all these
different universes so it makes sense
that every Marvel movie would kind of
have to be a collaboration as opposed to
being authored by one person at least
right now yeah of all the movies made by
committee you as you would say I'm
always the least angry at Marvel because
I get what they're trying to do and I
proven that it works well yeah it seems
like they trust their directors but they
still have input yeah and and I and I
like that about them NASM I like that
because they are creative producers it's
like a bunch of JJ Abrams so they all
are
because Marvel is making its own movies
now that makes sense to me yeah I know
very basic information about comic books
I don't know [ __ ] about ant-man I like
what the villain is though in this looks
badass film looks really badass like a
wasp thing I just hope it's not that
thing where like you see the main guy
got the whole thing in her like this is
supposed to be a traitor who's supposed
to be the bad guy
yeah in the finale he gets a suit and
then he knows how to use the suit
perfectly yeah basically I don't want it
to be Iron Man yeah with that sense I
love Iron Man but that's not one plot
part ROM like
how do you figure out this suit so well
yeah and I hope that this is a good in
and formidable villain because of all
the things Marvel is good at it seems
like they do have at least somewhat of
an issue making their villains truly
scary yeah we remember their villains
don't really
yeah cuz there are some villains to do
there and lately it seems like there's
been trouble making them memorable it's
like yeah I really like this movie the
feel that I never really thought it was
gonna win though like you know that's
not all Marvel villains by the way just
want to clarify that when you know these
characters are gonna come back it's like
that's the biggest challenge is making
the ones truly scary my last thing I got
to say is with Paul Rudd at first I was
like okay him being a thief just a
normal thief and stuff I was like I
don't know if I could buy that but the
second he was with the suit I'm like
Paul Rudd was perfectly cast what I is
the perfect choice
I hope so cuz that goes along with the
tone for me is like this will be the
sort of proving ground because he's
gonna have to have his natural comedic
charm but also he's gonna have to
transition into being believably badass
yeah like you know skilled and badass
and and formidable as a force he's not
just a normal sarcastic guy rating
system time oh [ __ ] what's the rating
today definitely I'm gonna go to see it
theaters
anyway guys if you're near the channel
you can subscribe to the Rio rejects and
Jerry has a playlist on this channel
check it out reasons to Jerry follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
oh I have an Instagram now it's also
resistant reasons to Jerry his Instagram
and yeah you should follow us because we
are youtubers mm-hmm we have social
networks we plug in and communicate to
fans so that a wild tamanna wash she is
a subscriber female subscriber very cute
female subscriber don't know how old you
are so we're gonna keep it up at
Savannah is a very dedicated female
subscriber really interactive with the
channel I just want to shatter out
because ladies we want to hear from more
of you Savannah is leading the way yes
her last name is wild she's a crazy ass
woman who's your sister Olivia Wilde huh
you know what your favorite movie is
into the wind of the wild do people say
you're like Neve Campbell because you do
wild things when you and your family get
together you refer to as the Wild Bunch